I put it to Bryce and I said, Bryce, do you know why it's so special? I think I got it pretty quickly actually. Oh man, so now we're going to do there where he said, I'm pretty sure I got it pretty quickly. And then I'm going to go and go back to what it was because I'm pretty sure, I'm pretty sure it took a little bit of hand-holding. welcome to adsp the podcast episode 54 recorded on november 23rd 2021 my name is connor and today with my co-host bryce we program partition live in bqn and then talk about why it's so awesome. All righty. So now we might have missed it. The good thing, Connor, though, is that you've chosen to solve this problem in this.
I put it to Bryce and I said, Bryce, do you know why it's so special? I think I got it pretty quickly actually. Oh man, so now we're going to do there where he said, I'm pretty sure I got it pretty quickly. And then I'm going to go and go back to what it was because I'm pretty sure, I'm pretty sure it took a little bit of hand-holding. welcome to adsp the podcast episode 54 recorded on november 23rd 2021 my name is connor and today with my co-host bryce we program partition live in bqn and then talk about why it's so awesome. All righty. So now we might have missed it. The good thing, Connor, though, is that you've chosen to solve this problem in this.|||我向布莱斯提出这个问题，我说，布莱斯，你知道为什么它这么特别吗？其实我当时觉得我挺快就想到了。天哪，现在我们要回到他说的那个场景，当时他说，“我确信我挺快就想到了。”然后我要回到原来的状态，因为我确信，我确信这需要一点引导。欢迎来到 adsp 播客第 54 期，录制于 2021 年 11 月 23 日。我是康纳，今天我的联合主持人是布莱斯，我们在 BQN 中现场编写了 partition 程序，然后讨论了它为什么这么棒。好了。所以现在我们可能错过了。不过好的一点是，康纳，你选择用这种方式来解决这个问题。
This is BQN? Yeah, BQN. In BQN, which means that, yes, last time you got, you know, we lost lost this great exciting discovery of me um you know sort of figuring out um like as you were showing me how like the language worked and like how to solve this problem but it's so esoteric that you were going to get to rediscover that all over again we'll see i'll actually be interested to be to compare how quickly you pick up what you learned and potentially completely forgot last time. So what we're doing for the next hopefully less than 30 minutes is we're taking a look at this partition problem that we explained in last episode. And we are going to be moving, I believe it's the odd numbers to the front and the even numbers to the back, which Bryce astutely pointed out is just a single algorithm in C++, which is std partition.
This is BQN? Yeah, BQN. In BQN, which means that, yes, last time you got, you know, we lost lost this great exciting discovery of me um you know sort of figuring out um like as you were showing me how like the language worked and like how to solve this problem but it's so esoteric that you were going to get to rediscover that all over again we'll see i'll actually be interested to be to compare how quickly you pick up what you learned and potentially completely forgot last time. So what we're doing for the next hopefully less than 30 minutes is we're taking a look at this partition problem that we explained in last episode. And we are going to be moving, I believe it's the odd numbers to the front and the even numbers to the back, which Bryce astutely pointed out is just a single algorithm in C++, which is std partition.|||这是 BQN 吗？对，BQN。在 BQN 中，这意味着，是的，上次你，你知道的，我们失去了这个令人兴奋的伟大发现：我，嗯，你知道的，在你想向我展示语言是如何运作的以及如何解决这个问题的过程中弄明白了它，但它是如此晦涩难懂，以至于你将不得不重新发现这一切。我们会看到的，其实我很有兴趣对比一下，你重新拾起上次学到却可能完全忘光的内容会有多快。所以，在接下来希望不到 30 分钟的时间里，我们来看看我们在上一期节目中解释过的这个 partition 问题。我们将要把，我记得是奇数移到前面，偶数移到后面，布莱斯敏锐地指出，这在 C++ 中其实就是一个单一的算法，也就是 std partition。
And we're going to solve that in an array language. So the first thing that we need to do, which, you know, so like as we said, Bryce have done this before, but we're still going to go at the same, try to go at the same speed as we did last time, is we want to create two different masks, a.k.a. Boolean masks. And a Boolean in an array language is a one or a zero that correspond to the even elements into the odd elements so if you do
And we're going to solve that in an array language. So the first thing that we need to do, which, you know, so like as we said, Bryce have done this before, but we're still going to go at the same, try to go at the same speed as we did last time, is we want to create two different masks, a.k.a. Boolean masks. And a Boolean in an array language is a one or a zero that correspond to the even elements into the odd elements so if you do|||我们要用数组语言来解决这个问题。所以我们要做的第一件事是——正如我们所说，布莱斯以前做过这个，但我们还是会以和上次相同的速度来进行——我们想要创建两个不同的掩码，也就是布尔掩码。在数组语言中，布尔值是一个 1 或 0，分别对应偶数元素和奇数元素，所以如果你执行
modulus two this pipe is the modulus operator you then all right and in bqn so i guess i should explain uh apl is the og array language bqN is the newest array language on the block. If you take the A and add one, you get B. If you take the P and add one, you get Q. And if you take the L and add two, you get N. And that's because Marshall messed up when he was rotating the letters by one. Wait, no, is that really the story? Yeah.
modulus two this pipe is the modulus operator you then all right and in bqn so i guess i should explain uh apl is the og array language bqN is the newest array language on the block. If you take the A and add one, you get B. If you take the P and add one, you get Q. And if you take the L and add two, you get N. And that's because Marshall messed up when he was rotating the letters by one. Wait, no, is that really the story? Yeah.|||取模 2（这个竖线是取模运算符），那么好吧，在 BQN 中——我想我应该解释一下，APL 是元老级的数组语言，而 BQN 是新近崛起的数组语言。如果你把 A 加 1，就得到了 B。如果你把 P 加 1，就得到了 Q。如果你把 L 加 2，就得到了 N。那是因为马歇尔在把字母旋转 1 位时搞砸了。等等，不对，这真的是那个故事吗？是的。
You've got to be be kidding the name of the language is on off by one error yeah yeah and and uh there was a backronym that um i think is sort of big question notation that you know it's a you know apl and started as a notation for mathematics and bqn is the next evolution of it that is used for answering big questions and that once the backronym had been set then it was like oh it's too late to go and fix it and bqn does sound a little bit better than bqm uh and so we just he just kept it like that yes i'm not gonna say what bqm sounds like bqn no bqm i don't know sounds like sounds like something dirty bqn though i feel like that's what you am i don't know get your head out of the gutter man it also has it can
You've got to be be kidding the name of the language is on off by one error yeah yeah and and uh there was a backronym that um i think is sort of big question notation that you know it's a you know apl and started as a notation for mathematics and bqn is the next evolution of it that is used for answering big questions and that once the backronym had been set then it was like oh it's too late to go and fix it and bqn does sound a little bit better than bqm uh and so we just he just kept it like that yes i'm not gonna say what bqm sounds like bqn no bqm i don't know sounds like sounds like something dirty bqn though i feel like that's what you am i don't know get your head out of the gutter man it also has it can|||你一定在开玩笑，这个语言的名字居然是一个“差一错误（off-by-one error）”！对，对，而且，还有一个反向首字母缩略词（backronym），嗯，我觉得有点像是“宏大问题记号（big question notation）”，你知道的，这是一个，你知道的，APL 最初是作为数学符号开始的，而 BQN 是它的下一次演进，用于回答宏大问题。一旦这个反向首字母缩略词确定下来后，就会觉得“哦，现在去修复它已经太迟了”，而且 BQN 听起来确实比 BQM 要好一点，所以我们——他干脆就保留了它。是的，我才不说 BQM 听起来像什么呢，BQN——不，BQM，我不知道，听起来像，听起来像什么脏东西。不过 BQN，我觉得这就是你——我是说，别满脑子都是黄色废料了，老兄！它还有，它可以
be pronounced uh so apl sort of has an alternate pronunciation um as apple and bqn has an alternate pronunciation of bacon um okay anyways we've uh so i was i'm screen sharing with bryce right now so we'll talk you through this the first thing that i did was to pipe piping the modulus operator and then one two three four is there a way to record ah fine forget it all right all right all right you'll just i will i will i will release a youtube video this Friday, or maybe next Friday, which is when this is coming out. You said that after the last time we recorded this episode. But then we lost all the stuff.
be pronounced uh so apl sort of has an alternate pronunciation um as apple and bqn has an alternate pronunciation of bacon um okay anyways we've uh so i was i'm screen sharing with bryce right now so we'll talk you through this the first thing that I did was to pipe piping the modulus operator and then one two three four is there a way to record ah fine forget it all right all right all right you'll just i will i will i will release a youtube video this Friday, or maybe next Friday, which is when this is coming out. You said that after the last time we recorded this episode. But then we lost all the stuff.|||被读作——嗯，所以 APL 有一种备用发音，嗯，就像 apple（苹果），而 BQN 有一种备用发音叫 bacon（培根）。好吧，不管怎样，我们——所以我现在正与布莱斯共享屏幕，所以我们会向你逐步讲解这个过程。我做的第一件事就是使用管道符串联取模运算符，然后是 1 2 3 4。有什么办法能录制吗？啊，算了，忘了吧。好吧，好吧，好吧，你——我会在本周五，或者下周五发布一个 YouTube 视频，也就是本期节目上线的时候。你在上次录完这期节目后也这么说过。但后来我们把所有东西都弄丢了。
We lost all the footage. So it's supposed to go out the day that this also goes out. But APL, in order to create an array, you just put space-separated numbers. But in BQN, you don't have that. You have to put this little sort of smiley face under bar to create an array. So if you do two modulus, one, two, three, four, you get one, zero, one, zero, where the one is corresponding to the odd numbers. Now, in order to filter these basically out and just sort of copy the odd elements, you want
We lost all the footage. So it's supposed to go out the day that this also goes out. But APL, in order to create an array, you just put space-separated numbers. But in BQN, you don't have that. You have to put this little sort of smiley face under bar to create an array. So if you do two modulus, one, two, three, four, you get one, zero, one, zero, where the one is corresponding to the odd numbers. Now, in order to filter these basically out and just sort of copy the odd elements, you want|||我们丢失了所有的素材。所以它本该在这一期播客发布的同一天上线。但在 APL 中，要想创建一个数组，你只需要输入用空格分隔的数字就行了。但在 BQN 中，你不能那样做。你必须加上这个类似笑脸加下划线的符号来创建一个数组。所以如果你执行 2 取模 1、2、3、4，你就会得到 1、0、1、0，其中 1 对应的是奇数。现在，为了基本上过滤掉这些元素并只复制奇数元素，你想要
to use a fork. So let's explain this. This is an S prime combinator. We explained this last time. Where you have three functions, where it's three functions in parentheses, A, B, and C. A and C are unary functions, and b is a binary function where the evaluation, and so the argument is x here, the evaluation is b of a of x comma c of x. So basically you pass your argument x to a and c, evaluate those, and then pass the results of those to your binary function B.
to use a fork. So let's explain this. This is an S prime combinator. We explained this last time. Where you have three functions, where it's three functions in parentheses, A, B, and C. A and C are unary functions, and b is a binary function where the evaluation, and so the argument is x here, the evaluation is b of a of x comma c of x. So basically you pass your argument x to a and c, evaluate those, and then pass the results of those to your binary function B.|||使用一个分叉（fork）。让我们来解释一下。这是一个 S 撇组合子（S prime combinator）。我们上次解释过。你有三个函数，它们是括号内的三个函数，A、B 和 C。A 和 C 是一元函数，而 B 是一个二元函数，其求值方式是——参数在这里是 x——求值结果为 b(a(x), c(x))。所以基本上，你将参数 x 传给 a 和 c，对它们进行求值，然后将这些结果传给你的二元函数 B。
So our first unary function here is going to be the composition or the binding of two to the modulus operator. So modulus is a binary function, but if we compose this, I think that's the right one, we are going to get our one zero, and I need to comment out these little explanation things here. And then B and C. For C, we want the identity function. And then in between the identity function and our partially applied to modulus, we want to put basically filter. And if we get this, this does not work because i think so so so the idea is that uh filter is a function that takes two sequences one that is you know this um boolean mask
So our first unary function here is going to be the composition or the binding of two to the modulus operator. So modulus is a binary function, but if we compose this, I think that's the right one, we are going to get our one zero, and I need to comment out these little explanation things here. And then B and C. For C, we want the identity function. And then in between the identity function and our partially applied to modulus, we want to put basically filter. And if we get this, this does not work because i think so so so the idea is that uh filter is a function that takes two sequences one that is you know this um boolean mask|||所以这里我们的第一个一元函数将是 2 与取模运算符的复合或绑定。因此，取模是一个二元函数，但如果我们将其复合——我认为这是正确的方式——我们将得到我们的 1 0，我需要把这里这些小解释给注释掉。然后是 B 和 C。对于 C，我们想要恒等函数（identity function）。然后在恒等函数和我们的部分应用的取模函数之间，我们基本上想放入 filter。如果我们得到这个，这行不通，因为——我认为，所以，所以这个想法是，呃，filter 是一个接受两个序列的函数，一个是，你知道的，这个，嗯，布尔掩码
boolean mask um as the first argument um and the second sequence is the elements. And then for each element in the Boolean mass sequence that's true, it keeps the corresponding element from the second sequence. Correct. Exactly, yeah. And so initially, my partially applied to modulus wasn't working because I was using a composition operator called a top, and I needed to use one called before to partially apply but that's a detail and so thinking about this in c++ terms I think the the equivalent would be something like a um I was gonna say I was gonna say a copy if but i think that actually that's
boolean mask um as the first argument um and the second sequence is the elements. And then for each element in the Boolean mass sequence that's true, it keeps the corresponding element from the second sequence. Correct. Exactly, yeah. And so initially, my partially applied to modulus wasn't working because I was using a composition operator called a top, and I needed to use one called before to partially apply but that's a detail and so thinking about this in c++ terms I think the the equivalent would be something like a um I was gonna say I was gonna say a copy if but i think that actually that's|||布尔掩码，嗯，作为第一个参数，嗯，第二个序列是这些元素。然后对于布尔掩码序列中为真的每个元素，它会保留第二个序列中对应的元素。没错。完全正确，是的。所以最初，我部分应用的取模函数无法正常工作，因为我使用的是一个叫做“top”的复合运算符，而我需要使用一个叫做“before”的运算符来进行部分应用，但这只是个细节。如果用 C++ 的术语来思考这个问题，我认为等价的东西大概类似于，嗯，我本想说，我本想说 copy_if，但我觉得实际上那
that's not the um the best way to mentally model this um i think probably the way and i say that because copy if is like is like one of these algorithms that's like it's already a composition of two different like things of like copying and in the filtering like it does you could do this with the copy if but i think it's probably something like a copy with a with some range piped in i don't know what do you think i think i think copy if is exactly what this is. Yes. Technically it's all bundled into one algorithm,
that's not the um the best way to mentally model this um i think probably the way and i say that because copy if is like is like one of these algorithms that's like it's already a composition of two different like things of like copying and in the filtering like it does you could do this with the copy if but i think it's probably something like a copy with a with some range piped in i don't know what do you think i think i think copy if is exactly what this is. Yes. Technically it's all bundled into one algorithm,|||并不是在脑海中对它建模的最佳方式。嗯，我之所以这么说，是因为 copy_if 就像是那种本身就已经由两种不同事物（即复制和过滤）组合而成的算法。你可以用 copy_if 来做到这一点，但我认为它可能更像是带有一些通过管道传入的范围的 copy。我不知道，你觉得呢？我觉得，我觉得 copy_if 正好就是这个。是的。从技术上讲，它都被打包进了一个算法中，
but like what we're doing here, the creation of a Boolean mask that is being used to copy elements is not actually possible with C plus plus standard algorithms. No, no, with like a trans like that. That's what I'm thinking. You know how all of the, all of like the, the range algorithms. No, no, no. With like a transfer. Like that's what I'm thinking. You know how all of the range algorithms, they have that.
but like what we're doing here, the creation of a Boolean mask that is being used to copy elements is not actually possible with C plus plus standard algorithms. No, no, with like a trans like that. That's what I'm thinking. You know how all of the, all of like the, the range algorithms. No, no, no. With like a transfer. Like that's what I'm thinking. You know how all of the range algorithms, they have that.|||但就像我们在这里做的一样，创建用于复制元素的布尔掩码，实际上用 C++ 标准算法是无法做到的。不，不，比如用类似 trans 的……这就是我的想法。你知道所有的，所有的那些，范围算法。不，不，不。比如用 transfer。这就是我的想法。你知道所有的范围算法，它们都有那个。
Projection? Yeah, the projection. Yeah. So the thing is what the projection will do is it will modify your sequence before you copy it, which is not exactly what we want. However, there is an algorithm that exists where you can provide it. I won't give you the name of it because it's a dead giveaway if I do that, but you can provide it with an alternate sequence that represents the Booleans that are exactly what we're doing here. So you basically have a copy if algorithm that you provided a range that you're going to be
Projection? Yeah, the projection. Yeah. So the thing is what the projection will do is it will modify your sequence before you copy it, which is not exactly what we want. However, there is an algorithm that exists where you can provide it. I won't give you the name of it because it's a dead giveaway if I do that, but you can provide it with an alternate sequence that represents the Booleans that are exactly what we're doing here. So you basically have a copy if algorithm that you provided a range that you're going to be|||投影（Projection）？对，投影。对。所以问题在于，投影的作用是在你复制之前修改你的序列，这并不完全是我们想要的。然而，确实存在这样一种算法，你可以向它提供——我不告诉你它的名字，因为如果我说了就太明显了——但你可以为它提供一个替代序列，它表示布尔值，这正是我们在这里所做的。所以你基本上拥有一个 copy_if 算法，你为其提供了一个范围，你将对这个范围进行
conditionally copying elements. But instead of using that sequence with a predicate to determine do I want to copy these, you provide it a secondary sequence and a predicate. And based on the evaluation of that unary predicate on the alternate sequence, you copy from the original range. And so that alternate sequence has a name. And that'll be the hint that I give you. If I tell you that that you'll probably instantly know the algorithm um although the algorithm is copy if there's another huge hint it's just not the
conditionally copying elements. But instead of using that sequence with a predicate to determine do I want to copy these, you provide it a secondary sequence and a predicate. And based on the evaluation of that unary predicate on the alternate sequence, you copy from the original range. And so that alternate sequence has a name. And that'll be the hint that I give you. If I tell you that that you'll probably instantly know the algorithm um although the algorithm is copy if there's another huge hint it's just not the|||条件复制元素。但你不是用该序列配合一个谓词来决定“我是否想复制这些”，而是为它提供一个辅助序列和一个谓词。根据一元谓词在替代序列上的求值结果，你从原始范围进行复制。所以这个替代序列有一个名字。这就是我要给你的提示。如果我告诉你那个名字，你大概会瞬间知道这个算法——尽管该算法就是 copy_if，这里还有另一个巨大的提示，它只是不属于
c++ standard uh copy oh wait this isn't a c++ standard algorithm that you're it is a c++ algorithm just not a standard algorithm it's not in the algorithm header. Oh, it's a numeric algorithm? It's not. That would also be a standard algorithm. Okay. It's not in the standard library. It's not provided by the standard library. Is it provided by Thrust?
c++ standard uh copy oh wait this isn't a c++ standard algorithm that you're it is a c++ algorithm just not a standard algorithm it's not in the algorithm header. Oh, it's a numeric algorithm? It's not. That would also be a standard algorithm. Okay. It's not in the standard library. It's not provided by the library. Is it provided by Thrust?|||C++ 标准的，呃，copy。哦，等等，这不是你提到的那个 C++ 标准算法——它是 C++ 算法，只是不是标准算法，它不在 algorithm 头文件中。哦，它是数值算法？不是。那也属于标准算法。好吧。它不在标准库中。它不是由标准库提供的。它是由 Thrust 提供的吗？
It is provided by Thrust. This podcast is just like, it's just constantly Connor teaching me stuff about the library that i'm supposed to be in charge of although it's not actually true it's these days there's a the there's another person on my team allison who's taken over uh uh maintaining um thrust so i'm no longer the glorious leader of Thrust, which is great. Like, you know, just you should always just delegate your job off to other people. But that does not mean that I should not know these things. Yeah. So when I discovered the stencil overload of copy of, it is such an extremely useful algorithm because there are so many situations where
It is provided by Thrust. This podcast is just like, it's just constantly Connor teaching me stuff about the library that i'm supposed to be in charge of although it's not actually true it's these days there's a the there's another person on my team allison who's taken over uh uh maintaining um thrust so i'm no longer the glorious leader of Thrust, which is great. Like, you know, just you should always just delegate your job off to other people. But that does not mean that I should not know these things. Yeah. So when I discovered the stencil overload of copy of, it is such an extremely useful algorithm because there are so many situations where|||它是由 Thrust 提供的。这个播客简直就是——康纳在不断地教我关于我本该负责的那个库的知识，尽管实际上并非如此，现在我团队里有另一个人艾莉森（Allison），她接管了，呃，维护，呃，Thrust 的工作，所以我不再是 Thrust 辉煌的领导者了，这挺好的。就像，你知道的，你总是应该把工作委派给其他人。但这并不意味着我不该知道这些事情。是的。所以当我发现 copy_if 的 stencil 重载时，它是一个极其有用的算法，因为在很多情况下，
exactly what that overload provides you with is what you want to do you want to conditionally copy something based on some other sequence and so that alternate sequence is called the stencil yeah which is actually not the best name because it's sort of close to like a tile and that's something completely different yeah but uh the stencil overloads and they exist for a ton of algorithms and thrust basically um and sometimes you actually so you in in the c++ standard algorithms you usually only end up with we'll call them like sets of one or two iterators so like one that'll provide you the input range and potentially one that provides you the output range but in thrust, you can end up with three sets. And I say sets because a lot of these algorithms, as soon as you
exactly what that overload provides you with is what you want to do you want to conditionally copy something based on some other sequence and so that alternate sequence is called the stencil yeah which is actually not the best name because it's sort of close to like a tile and that's something completely different yeah but uh the stencil overloads and they exist for a ton of algorithms and thrust basically um and sometimes you actually so you in in the c++ standard algorithms you usually only end up with we'll call them like sets of one or two iterators so like one that'll provide you the input range and potentially one that provides you the output range but in thrust, you can end up with three sets. And I say sets because a lot of these algorithms, as soon as you|||那个重载所提供给你的恰恰就是你想做的事情：你想根据其他某个序列来条件性地复制某些东西，所以那个替代序列被称为 stencil（模板/stencil）。是的，这其实并不是最好的名字，因为它有点接近于 tile（瓦片），而那是完全不同的东西。是的，但是，stencil 重载基本上存在于 Thrust 的大量算法中，而且有时你实际上——你在 C++ 标准算法中，通常最终只有——我们称之为一组或两组迭代器，比如一个提供输入范围，另一个可能提供输出范围；但在 Thrust 中，你可能会有多达三组。我说“组”是因为其中许多算法，一旦你
specify two iterators, begin and end for one range, you only need to specify the first one for the other two ranges. Right. Because it's going to assume that the size of all of the other ranges is the same as the size of the first or something like that or or where there's other assumptions about the size you know that it's um for something like a copy if you know you don't know what the size you don't know how many times you're going to write to the output um but you know that it's going to be less than n for example so here's a and so this this algorithm is perfect so you're going to end up copy if your original sequence is the one two three four your secondary sequence would be uh i would do it with a thrust make transform iterator that's basically doing uh what we're
specify two iterators, begin and end for one range, you only need to specify the first one for the other two ranges. Right. Because it's going to assume that the size of all of the other ranges is the same as the size of the first or something like that or or where there's other assumptions about the size you know that it's um for something like a copy if you know you don't know what the size you don't know how many times you're going to write to the output um but you know that it's going to be less than n for example so here's a and so this this algorithm is perfect so you're going to end up copy if your original sequence is the one two three four your secondary sequence would be uh i would do it with a thrust make transform iterator that's basically doing what we're|||指定了两个迭代器（即一个范围的 begin 和 end），对于另外两个范围，你只需要指定第一个迭代器就行了。对。因为它们会假定所有其他范围的大小与第一个范围的大小相同，或者诸如此类，或者对大小有其他假设，你知道的，对于像 copy_if 这样的算法，你知道你不知道大小是多少，你不知道你要向输出写入多少次，但你知道它会小于 n，举个例子。所以这里有一个，这个算法是完美的，所以你最终会进行 copy_if，如果你的原始序列是 1 2 3 4，你的辅助序列将是——我会用 thrust::make_transform_iterator 来做，它基本上在做我们正在做的
doing here the two modulus which is then gonna sort of on demand generate you your your ones and zeros are true and false so the question is what's the unary predicate that you are going to pass as the final argument to this that'll be applied to your um and technically wait wait okay so you have the copy if with the stencil and then the the first the one of them is this transform iterator um sequence that makes sense and then you're asking what is what what are you asking so there's and there's a final unary predicate that is applied to your stencil. Why? Well, so this is sort of, as I'm asking this, I realize the question doesn't make sense.
doing here the two modulus which is then gonna sort of on demand generate you your your ones and zeros are true and false so the question is what's the unary predicate that you are going to pass as the final argument to this that'll be applied to your um and technically wait wait okay so you have the copy if with the stencil and then the the first the one of them is this transform iterator um sequence that makes sense and then you're asking what is what what are you asking so there's and there's a final unary predicate that is applied to your stencil. Why? Well, so this is sort of, as I'm asking this, I realize the question doesn't make sense.|||这里的事情：2 取模，然后它会按需生成你的 1 和 0（即真和假）。所以问题是，你将作为最后一个参数传递给它的一元谓词是什么，它将被应用于你的——从技术上讲，等等，等等，好吧，所以你有带 stencil 的 copy_if，然后第一个，其中一个是这个 transform_iterator 序列，这讲得通；然后你在问，什么是什么，你在问什么？所以还有一个最终的一元谓词，它被应用到你的 stencil 上。为什么？嗯，所以这有点像，当我问出这句话时，我意识到这个问题根本说不通。
It would just be the identity. Exactly. So thrust identity is what you would use. So that's the thing, is trying to model what we're doing here in BQN. That copy if, pass the sequence, 1, 2 sequence one two three four past the transform iterator that does the two modulus and thrust identity that's what maps to this because the transform that does the two modulus is the two uh composed with pipe um the the filter is our copy if and identity is the thrust identity however that being said in c++ you wouldn't really do that. You don't actually need the stencil overload.
It would just be the identity. Exactly. So thrust identity is what you would use. So that's the thing, is trying to model what we're doing here in BQN. That copy if, pass the sequence, 1, 2 sequence one two three four past the transform iterator that does the two modulus and thrust identity that's what maps to this because the transform that does the two modulus is the two uh composed with pipe um the the filter is our copy if and identity is the thrust identity however that being said in c++ you wouldn't really do that. You don't actually need the stencil overload.|||那不就是 identity（恒等）吗？完全正确。所以你会使用 thrust::identity。这就是关键所在，试图在 C++ 中模拟我们在 BQN 中所做的事情。那个 copy_if，传入序列——1、2 序列，1 2 3 4 传给执行 2 取模的 transform_iterator，以及 thrust::identity，这正是与之对应的，因为执行 2 取模的转换是 2 与管道符复合，filter 就是我们的 copy_if，而 identity 就是 thrust::identity。然而话虽如此，在 C++ 中你实际上不会那样做。你其实并不需要 stencil 重载。
You would just use the overload where the unary predicate is doing the two modules. I was just talking about what is the most true way to model what you're doing here in C++. But the identity function here is different than the identity function in the copy if because the identity function in the copy if you're saying that in the cot the thrust stenciled copy if it applies this function to this the the stencil sequence in some ways it sort of reminds me of the by key algorithms i actually it's that seems a little silly to me it seems like we should have a copy of stenciled overload that does not take um uh a predicate function where it just assumes that the um uh that the the you know the the the mask sequence is convertible to bool um and just like you know just assumes that and tries it but i mean like you know it's that's that's that's not a super
You would just use the overload where the unary predicate is doing the two modules. I was just talking about what is the most true way to model what you're doing here in C++. But the identity function here is different than the identity function in the copy if because the identity function in the copy if you're saying that in the cot the thrust stenciled copy if it applies this function to this the the stencil sequence in some ways it sort of reminds me of the by key algorithms i actually it's that seems a little silly to me it seems like we should have a copy of stenciled overload that does not take um uh a predicate function where it just assumes that the um uh that the the you know the the the mask sequence is convertible to bool|||你只需使用一元谓词来执行 2 取模的那个重载即可。我刚才只是在讨论在 C++ 中模拟你在这里所做的事情的最真实的方式。但这里的恒等函数与 copy_if 中的恒等函数不同，因为在 copy_if 中——你是说在带 stencil 的 thrust copy_if 中，它将这个函数应用于 stencil 序列。从某些方面来看，这有点让我想起 by_key 算法，我实际上觉得这有点傻，我觉得我们应该拥有一个不接受谓词函数的带 stencil 的 copy_if 重载，它直接假定——呃——那个，你知道的，掩码序列可以转换为 bool
common use case so like i like, I get it. I mean, it comes up often. I mean, probably half the times I've used the copy of stencil overload, it's with thrust identity as the unary predicate. My next thought was like, well, just make it the default. But then I remembered, I don't really like default arguments. So, yeah, probably I would prefer just the overload. Yeah. All right.
and just like you know just assumes that and tries it but i mean like you know it's that's that's that's not a super common use case so like i like, I get it. I mean, comes up often. I mean, probably half the times I've used the copy of stencil overload, it's with thrust identity as the unary predicate. My next thought was like, well, just make it the default. But then I remembered, I don't really like default arguments. So, yeah, probably I would prefer just the overload. Yeah. All right.|||然后就像，你知道的，直接假定并尝试它。但我的意思是，你知道的，那并不是一个超级常见的用例，所以——我懂我的意思。我是说，这经常出现。我的意思是，我使用 copy_if 的 stencil 重载的次数中，大概有一半都是将 thrust::identity 作为一元谓词。我的下一个想法是，好吧，干脆把它设为默认值。但随后我想起来，我其实不太喜欢默认参数。所以，是的，我可能更倾向于直接提供重载。好吧。
All right. We should move on. All right. Yeah. We right. All right. We should move on. We should move on. All right. Yeah. We got 20 minutes left here. So we've got our ones and zeros. And then now we've used it with a S prime combinator that, you know, the binary operation is the filter or compress.
All right. We should move on. All right. Yeah. We right. All right. We should move on. We should move on. All right. Yeah. We got 20 minutes left here. So we've got our ones and zeros. And then now we've used it with a S prime combinator that, you know, the binary operation is the filter or compress.|||好吧。我们该继续了。好吧。是的。我们对。好吧。我们该继续了。我们该继续了。好吧。是的。我们这里还剩 20 分钟。所以我们已经有了 1 和 0。然后现在我们把它和一个 S 撇组合子结合使用，你知道的，其中的二元操作是 filter（过滤）或 compress（压缩）。
And then we're passing the mask and identity, which gives us basically 1010 with the one, zero, with the binary operation filter in between, and then one, two, three, four, and it leaves you with one and three. So in order to get our odd numbers at the front and our even numbers at the back, we basically just want to copy this little fork here and put them next to each other. And so I think I asked you last time,
And then we're passing the mask and identity, which gives us basically 1010 with the one, zero, with the binary operation filter in between, and then one, two, three, four, and it leaves you with one and three. So in order to get our odd numbers at the front and our even numbers at the back, we basically just want to copy this little fork here and put them next to each other. And so I think I asked you last time,|||然后我们传递掩码和 identity，这基本上给了我们 1 0 1 0，中间夹着二元操作 filter，然后是 1、2、3、4，结果会留下 1 和 3。所以为了让我们的奇数在前面、偶数在后面，我们基本上只需复制这里的这个小分叉，然后把它们并排放在一起。所以我想我上次问过你，
what do you think this evaluates to where, and it's actually not comma, it is this little sideways, backwards S looking like thing. So this is catenate. This joins two lists together. So what do you think both of these? This will just give you 1, 3, 1, 3, right? Correct. Yeah.
what do you think this evaluates to where, and it's actually not comma, it is this little sideways, backwards S looking like thing. So this is catenate. This joins two lists together. So what do you think both of these? This will just give you 1, 3, 1, 3, right? Correct. Yeah.|||你认为这会被求值为什么——而且实际上不是逗号，而是这个侧向的、反向的看起来像 S 的东西。所以这是 catenate（连接）。它将两个列表连接在一起。所以你认为这两个结合起来是什么？这只会给你 1, 3, 1, 3，对吧？正确。是的。
So if you copy this and catenate the result of each of them, you just get 1, 3, 1, 3. So what we want to do basically is just in this second fork that is just currently equal to our first fork on the left, we want to basically change our ones to zeros and zeros to ones. And there's a function in BQN and in APL called not. And if we, I think if we just put this in parentheses and evaluate this, we should get that. So now we have odd numbers at the front, even numbers at the back. I can't even remember what the problem originally stated,
So if you copy this and catenate the result of each of them, you just get 1, 3, 1, 3. So what we want to do basically is just in this second fork that is just currently equal to our first fork on the left, we want to basically change our ones to zeros and zeros to ones. And there's a function in BQN and in APL called not. And if we, I think if we just put this in parentheses and evaluate this, we should get that. So now we have odd numbers at the front, even numbers at the back. I can't even remember what the problem originally stated,|||所以如果你复制这个并将它们各自的结果连接起来，你只会得到 1, 3, 1, 3。所以我们基本上想做的是，在这个目前刚好等于我们左侧第一个分叉的第二个分叉中，我们基本上想把 1 改成 0，把 0 改成 1。在 BQN 和 APL 中有一个叫做 not 的函数。如果我们——我想如果我们把它放在括号里求值，我们应该就能得到那个结果。所以现在我们把奇数放在前面，偶数放在后面。我甚至不记得题目原来是怎么说的了，
but you know, it doesn't really matter. I think it might've been the other way around. And yeah, but I don't think it really matters. It's simple enough to change it there. But I seemed, well, I was pretty happy with this the first time around. I seem to recall that you were, yeah, you got to put the pipe around. Come on, Connor. Even I could see that was going to be a problem. So, yeah, you were happy at this point. And I think you had even remarked, maybe we'll go find, we'll go find previous Bryce because we do have his audio.
but you know, it doesn't really matter. I think it might've been the other way around. And yeah, but I don't think it really matters. It's simple enough to change it there. But I seemed, well, I was pretty happy with this the first time around. I seem to recall that you were, yeah, you got to put the pipe around. Come on, Connor. Even I could see that was going to be a problem. So, yeah, you were happy at this point. And I think you had even remarked, maybe we'll go find, we'll go find previous Bryce because we do have his audio.|||但你知道，这其实无所谓。我想可能刚好相反。是的，但我认为这真的不重要。在那里修改它足够简单。但我似乎——好吧，我第一次看到这个时挺高兴的。我记得你当时——对，你得在周围加上竖线。得了吧，康纳。连我都能看出那会是个问题。所以，是的，你当时很高兴。而且我想你甚至还说过，也许我们会去找，我们会去找之前的布莱斯，因为我们确实保留了他的音频。
And he says, this actually, it looks noisy, but it actually does make sense. Yeah. Insert Bryson. You were like too many too many parentheses correct yeah when i look at this solution there's one two three uh four times two is eight different parentheses and more important so like this many parentheses tells me that like this is not the ideal apl or bqn solution but on of that, we have so much duplication here. We basically have the two composed with modulus slash identity.
And he says, this actually, it looks noisy, but it actually does make sense. Yeah. Insert Bryson. You were like too many too many parentheses correct yeah when i look at this solution there's one two three uh four times two is eight different parentheses and more important so like this many parentheses tells me that like this is not the ideal apl or bqn solution but on of that, we have so much duplication here. We basically have the two composed with modulus slash identity.|||他当时说：“这实际上，看起来很繁杂，但它确实讲得通。”是的。（插入布莱斯的声音）你当时说：“括号太多了，太多了。”没错，是的，当我看到这个解法时，有 1、2、3，呃，4 乘以 2 等于 8 个不同的括号，更重要的是，这么多的括号告诉我，这并不是理想的 APL 或 BQN 解法。不仅如此，这里还有太多的重复代码。我们基本上有两次“2 与取模/identity 复合”。
We have that twice. And then the only thing that's different between the two is that we're negating the two composed with modulus. So what can we do to make this better? So let us see if we can sort of extract out the identity and the replicate or the compress and to compose and go from there. So I can't actually remember how I did this
We have that twice. And then the only thing that's different between the two is that we're negating the two composed with modulus. So what can we do to make this better? So let us see if we can sort of extract out the identity and the replicate or the compress and to compose and go from there. So I can't actually remember how I did this|||我们有两次。然后这两者之间唯一的区别在于，我们对“2 与取模的复合”取了反。那么我们能做些什么来改进这一点呢？所以让我们看看是否可以把 identity、replicate（或 compress）以及复合操作提取出来，然后以此为基础继续。其实我记不清我是怎么做的了
in the previous video. But the first thing that we're going to try and do, so we're going to sort of do this. I had prepared last time to make sure I wasn't sort of meandering through this, but now we're going to meander through this. So we're going to try and, so let's see if we can,
in the previous video. But the first thing that we're going to try and do, so we're going to sort of do this. I had prepared last time to make sure I wasn't sort of meandering through this, but now we're going to meander through this. So we're going to try and, so let's see if we can,|||在之前的视频中。但我们要尝试做的第一件事是——所以我们要这么做。我上次做过准备，确保自己不会在其中绕弯子，但现在我们要绕弯子了。所以我们要尝试——让我们看看我们是否能够，
we need to put this in parentheses. So we've sort of factored out the two composed to the left and then the identity to the right. And then for our binary function in between these two things, we're just catenating for the moment. So what we have here is one, zero, one, zero,
we need to put this in parentheses. So we've sort of factored out the two composed to the left and then the identity to the right. And then for our binary function in between these two things, we're just catenating for the moment. So what we have here is one, zero, one, zero,|||我们需要把它放在括号里。所以我们基本上把左边的“2 复合”和右边的 identity 提取出来了。然后对于这两者之间的二元函数，目前我们只是进行连接（catenate）。所以我们这里有的是 1, 0, 1, 0，
and then one, two, three, four, all in the same array. And so now we can turn this inner fork, which is currently not a fork, so if we add an A and a C here, what we want to do is basically we want to basically turn each of these, I believe, into forks.
and then one, two, three, four, all in the same array. And so now we can turn this inner fork, which is currently not a fork, so if we add an A and a C here, what we want to do is basically we want to turn each of these, I believe, into forks.|||然后是 1, 2, 3, 4，都在同一个数组中。所以现在我们可以把这个内部的分叉——它目前还不是一个分叉，如果我们在这里添加一个 A 和一个 C，我们想做的是基本上把它们每一个，我相信，都变成一个分叉。
So let's just try and do that simply. And we'll use identity and so actually and this is where the explanation of a binary fork comes in so previously i explained when you have a fork it's two unary functions with a binary function sandwiched in between however which is what on the screen is sort of being described here you can also have and we'll call this x, y, and z, and then we'll call the input n here. You can have a binary version of this. We're actually, we'll call this a and b. So binary functions are infix, and unary functions are prefix. So that's why the x is on the right here, but the a and b sandwich, the a and b are arguments, and x and z are our binary functions that are going to be used first, and y is our
Let's just try and do that simply. And we'll use identity and so actually and this is where the explanation of a binary fork comes in so previously i explained when you have a fork it's two unary functions with a binary function sandwiched in between however which is what on the screen is sort of being described here you can also have and we'll call this x, y, and z, and then we'll call the input n here. You can have a binary version of this. We're actually, we'll call this a and b. So binary functions are infix, and unary functions are prefix. So that's why the x is on the right here, but the a and b sandwich, the a and b are arguments, and x and z are our binary functions that are going to be used first, and y is our|||让我们简单地尝试一下。我们将使用 identity——所以实际上，这里就要引入二元分叉（binary fork）的解释了：之前我解释过，当你有一个分叉时，它是两个一元函数，中间夹着一个二元函数；然而，正如屏幕上正在描述的那样，你也可以拥有——我们将其称为 x、y 和 z，然后我们称这里的输入为 n。你可以拥有它的二元版本。实际上，我们将其称为 a 和 b。所以二元函数是中缀的，一元函数是前缀的。这就是为什么 x 在这里是右操作数，而夹在中间的 a 和 b 是参数，x 和 z 是将首先被使用的二元函数，而 y 是我们的
binary function that's going to be used last this evaluates to the following so we have y of x of a comma b and then z of a comma b and parentheses so we're evaluating x and z passing a and b as arguments to both of those and then the results of those are being passed to our binary function y and so what we've done here for the moment is we've just used uh what was identity before but in a binary context the left and right tax which is basically look like sideways t's one's pointing to the right one's pointing to the left these are binary functions that just one takes the left argument one takes the right argument so if we do do this, and I have the right number... You have a straight C at the end there. Oh, right, yeah. And is this... I think we don't need that parentheses,
binary function that's going to be used last this evaluates to the following so we have y of x of a comma b and then z of a comma b and parentheses so we're evaluating x and z passing a and b as arguments to both of those and then the results of those are being passed to our binary function y and so what we've done here for the moment is we've just used uh what was identity before but in a binary context the left and right tax which is basically look like sideways t's one's pointing to the right one's pointing to the left these are binary functions that just one takes the left argument one takes the right argument so if we do do this, and I have the right number... You have a straight C at the end there. Oh, right, yeah. And is this... I think we don't need that parentheses,|||最后要使用的二元函数。这会被求值为：我们有 y(x(a, b), z(a, b))（带括号）。所以我们在对 x 和 z 求值，将 a 和 b 作为参数传递给这两者，然后将它们的结果传递给我们的二元函数 y。所以我们目前在这里所做的，仅仅是使用了——之前是 identity，但在二元语境下——left 和 right 操作符，它们基本上看起来像横向的 T 形，一个指向右，一个指向左，这些是二元函数，一个只取左参数，一个只取右参数。所以如果我们这样做，而且我的括号数量正确的话……你最后有一个纯粹的 C。哦，对，是的。这个……我想我们不需要那个括号，
and we need to comment out our explanation. So at the moment here, we've got because we don't have not being used anywhere. So basically the inner fork is just replicate with left and right on either side of it for the two outer binary functions and then catenate in the middle. But if we compose with this identity the not function, and it's going to be one of these, basically that not is going to change the mask from 1010 to 0101, and we're good to go.
and we need to comment out our explanation. So at the moment here, we've got because we don't have not being used anywhere. So basically the inner fork is just replicate with left and right on either side of it for the two outer binary functions and then catenate in the middle. But if we compose with this identity the not function, and it's going to be one of these, basically that not is going to change the mask from 1010 to 0101, and we're good to go.|||并且我们需要注释掉我们的解释。所以目前在这里，我们有——因为我们没有任何地方用到 not。所以基本上，内部的分叉就是 replicate（复制/压紧），其两侧分别是 left 和 right，作为外面两个二元函数，中间则是 catenate。但如果我们把 not 函数与这个 identity 复合——它将是其中之一，基本上那个 not 会把掩码从 1010 改为 0101，这样我们就大功告成了。
However, this looks pretty messy. still have i believe equal number of parentheses yeah still equal number of parentheses one fewer maybe no no i think yeah one two three four five six seven eight however we can we can clean this up so whenever you have a um a basically a binary fork where the left binary function is left and the right binary function is right, this is the exact same thing as just the middle binary function. Because that's what a binary function does. It takes two arguments, uses the left one on the left and the right one on the right, and you're good to go. So this will be the same thing. And then once you have gotten rid of the fork and you just have a binary function,
However, this looks pretty messy. still have i believe equal number of parentheses yeah still equal number of parentheses one fewer maybe no no i think yeah one two three four five six seven eight however we can we can clean this up so whenever you have a um a basically a binary fork where the left binary function is left and the right binary function is right, this is the exact same thing as just the middle binary function. Because that's what a binary function does. It takes two arguments, uses the left one on the left and the right one on the right, and you're good to go. So this will be the same thing. And then once you have gotten rid of the fork and you just have a binary function,|||然而，这看起来非常凌乱。我坚信括号数量还是同样多。是的，括号数量还是同样多，也许少了一个？不，不，我想是的，1、2、3、4、5、6、7、8。不过，我们可以清理一下。因此，每当你拥有一个——基本上是一个二元分叉，其中左边的二元函数是 left，右边的二元函数是 right，这与仅仅使用中间的二元函数完全是一回事。因为这就是二元函数的作用。它接受两个参数，在左边使用左参数，在右边使用右参数，这就行了。所以这会是完全相同的效果。然后，一旦你去掉了分叉，只剩下一个二元函数，
well, we don't need these parentheses. So now we're down to just basically, we reduced, what was that, four characters? All of it was just noise. So absolutely beautiful. Well, and I'd also argue that it, you know, it had, I think in practice, probably the BQN compiler optimizes this under the hood,
well, we don't need these parentheses. So now we're down to just basically, we reduced, what was that, four characters? All of it was just noise. So absolutely beautiful. Well, and I'd also argue that it, you know, it had, I think in practice, probably the BQN compiler optimizes this under the hood,|||好吧，我们就不需要这些括号了。所以现在我们基本上精简下来了，我们减少了——那是什么，四个字符？所有的括号都只是噪音。所以简直太美妙了。嗯，我还要争辩说，你知道的，它有——我认为在实践中，BQN 编译器可能在底层对这一点进行了优化，
but it looks more efficient because you're only building that mask once. Previously, you had two places where you built the same mask, and here you've lifted that out. Thing to note, though, BQN is actually not a compiled language. you had two places where you built the same mask. And here you've lifted that out. So yeah. Thing to note though, BQN is actually not a compiled language. Most array languages are interpreted. Whatever.
but it looks more efficient because you're only building that mask once. Previously, you had two places where you built the same mask, and here you've lifted that out. Yeah. Thing to note though, BQN is actually not a compiled language. you had two places where you built the same mask. And here you've lifted that out. So yeah. Thing to note though, BQN is actually not a compiled language. Most array languages are interpreted. Whatever.|||但它看起来更高效，因为你只构建了一次该掩码。以前，你有两个地方构建了相同的掩码，而在这里你把它提出来了。是的。不过需要注意的是，BQN 实际上并不是一种编译型语言。你以前有两个地方构建了相同的掩码。在这里你把它提出来了。所以，是的。不过需要注意的是，BQN 实际上并不是一种编译型语言。大多数数组语言都是解释型的。无所谓。
In compiler interpreter, the thing will do that optimization, I'll assume. And we're pretty close to being done this solution, but there was one last step that I showed last time where, because, so right now we've got our two composed modulus as our left outer fork function, and then identity, and that's what we started with. And then on the inside, we've got sort of basically a fork where on the right, it's just replicate or compress and then the binary function in between that one and the other one is catenate so you're going to end up with
In compiler interpreter, the thing will do that optimization, I'll assume. And we're pretty close to being done this solution, but there was one last step that I showed last time where, because, so right now we've got our two composed modulus as our left outer fork function, and then identity, and that's what we started with. And then on the inside, we've got sort of basically a fork where on the right, it's just replicate or compress and then the binary function in between that one and the other one is catenate so you're going to end up with|||无论是编译器还是解释器，都会做这种优化的，我猜。我们离完成这个解法已经非常近了，但还有最后一步是我上次展示过的，因为——所以现在我们有作为左外侧分叉函数的“2 与取模复合”，然后是 identity，这正是我们开始时的样子。而在内部，我们基本上有一个分叉，其右侧只是 replicate（或 compress），而它与另一个函数之间的二元函数是 catenate，所以你最终会得到
sort of one three as the result of everything catenated with at the beginning the result of basically are knotted or negate or not yeah knotted so you're the complement of one zero one zero which is going to be zero one zero one like I said, this is all probably lost to all the listeners, but there will be a YouTube video for those that are intrigued enough by this discussion to go and watch it. And it'll make sense probably more with visual cues.
sort of one three as the result of everything catenated with at the beginning the result of basically are knotted or negate or not yeah knotted so you're the complement of one zero one zero which is going to be zero one zero one like I said, this is all probably lost to all the listeners, but there will be a YouTube video for those that are intrigued enough by this discussion to go and watch it. And it'll make sense probably more with visual cues.|||比如 1 和 3 作为所有连接操作的结果，而在开头则是基本上被取反（not/negate）的结果——是的，取反（knotted）的结果。所以你是 1 0 1 0 的补集，也就是 0 1 0 1。就像我说的，对于所有听众来说，这些可能都听得云里雾里，但对于那些对这次讨论足够感兴趣而去看视频的人来说，会有一个 YouTube 视频。配合视觉提示，这可能会更好理解。
But we can switch the left and the right sort of binary functions in this inner fork so that it looks like this. And because the way that APL evaluates is right to left, we can now get rid of the two parentheses that are sort of containing this. Now, but I'm going to argue, and as I argued last time, that the parentheses actually added some clarity. To the uninitiated.
But we can switch the left and the right sort of binary functions in this inner fork so that it looks like this. And because the way that APL evaluates is right to left, we can now get rid of the two parentheses that are sort of containing this. Now, but I'm going to argue, and as I argued last time, that the parentheses actually added some clarity. To the uninitiated.|||但我们可以交换这个内部分叉中左右两边的二元函数，使其看起来像这样。而且由于 APL 的求值方式是从右到左的，我们现在可以去掉包含着这一部分的两个括号。不过我要争辩的是，正如我上次所说的那样，括号实际上增加了一些清晰度。对于外行人来说。
Yes. actually added some clarity um to the uninitiated yes but but like now now you're relying on people know knowing um how uh precedence works in this uh language like now there's just a soup of symbols in the middle of this and there's no there's no hierarchy or structure i think this is true i mean i prefer this because i have i have dived into the pool of knowledge that is the array world and um and also too we haven't even fully like so we've swapped the order but now the odd numbers are at the front and so this is where i think i got all excited last time i was like you know and this is where uh the C combinator comes in, a.k.a. flip from Haskell, a.k.a. the C combinator.
Yes. actually added some clarity um to the uninitiated yes but but like now now you're relying on people know knowing um how uh precedence works in this uh language like now there's just a soup of symbols in the middle of this and there's no there's no hierarchy or structure i think this is true i mean i prefer this because i have i have dived into the pool of knowledge that is the array world and um and also too we haven't even fully like so we've swapped the order but now the odd numbers are at the front and so this is where i think i got all excited last time i was like you know and this is where uh the C combinator comes in, a.k.a. flip from Haskell, a.k.a. the C combinator.|||是的。实际上确实增加了一些清晰度，嗯，对门外汉来说是的。但是——但是现在，你是在指望人们知道，嗯，优先级在这个语言中是如何运作的——就像现在这里只有一堆乱七八糟的符号，没有任何层次结构或结构。我认为确实如此。我的意思是，我更喜欢这样，因为我已经纵身跃入数组世界这个知识的海洋中，而且，我们甚至还没完全——所以我们交换了顺序，但现在奇数在前面了，这就是为什么我上次觉得兴奋无比，我就像，你知道的，这就是 C 组合子（C combinator）登场的地方，也就是 Haskell 中的 flip，也就是 C 组合子。
And that's this little squiggly superscript symbol here, and that basically reverses the order of the arguments passed to your binary function here being catenate, so we get back this. And that was even at that point I think Bryce was like was like okay no no no let's uh let's rewind here you took out two parentheses yeah and added a c combinator and i do not think that increased clarity we can agree to disagree although many people would just agree with you um and then yeah we can name this and once we name it as well, we can also get rid of a couple extra parentheses. But you could have done that with the previous solution as well.
And that's this little squiggly superscript symbol here, and that basically reverses the order of the arguments passed to your binary function here being catenate, so we get back this. And that was even at that point I think Bryce was like was like okay no no no let's uh let's rewind here you took out two parentheses yeah and added a c combinator and i do not think that increased clarity we can agree to disagree although many people would just agree with you um and then yeah we can name this and once we name it as well, we can also get rid of a couple extra parentheses. But you could have done that with the previous solution as well.|||这就是那个小小的弯曲的上标符号，它基本上会反转传递给你的二元函数（此处为 catenate）的参数顺序，于是我们恢复了这种形式。甚至在那时，布莱斯大概也是这种反应：“好吧，不，不，不，让我们——让我们倒带一下。你去掉了两个括号，是的，还加了一个 C 组合子，我不认为这增加了清晰度。”我们可以保留不同意见，尽管很多人会直接同意你的观点，然后，是的，我们可以给它命名。一旦我们给它命名了，我们也可以去掉多余的几个括号。但你对之前的解法也可以这样做。
We don't need the arrow here. And then, boom, that's what's up. So pretty freaking awesome. And I just love, you know, what was it? Just this past Sunday, the LeetCode contest happened. And then I was solving the solutions in APL and BQN. And it's just marvelous. I ended up using a psi combinator inside the S prime combinator, aka a fork, in order to apply a unary function twice to the result of two modified things.
We don't need the arrow here. And then, boom, that's what's up. So pretty freaking awesome. And I just love, you know, what was it? Just this past Sunday, the LeetCode contest happened. And then I was solving the solutions in APL and BQN. And it's just marvelous. I ended up using a psi combinator inside the S prime combinator, aka a fork, in order to apply a unary function twice to the result of two modified things.|||我们这里不需要箭头。然后，轰，就是这样。简直酷毙了。我太喜欢了，你知道的，那是怎么回事？就在上周日，LeetCode 周赛举行了。然后我用 APL 和 BQN 编写了解法。简直太妙了。我最终在 S 撇组合子（即分叉）内部使用了 psi 组合子，以便对两个修改后的结果连续两次应用一元函数。
That didn't make any sense, but it's just the power of APL and BQN and the operators that you get with it. So we're doing pretty good. We got 10 minutes left before we got to drop off. And at this point – Yeah, yeah, yeah. I was about to say at this point you got very excited. And, yes, at this point I got very excited.
That didn't make any sense, but it's just the power of APL and BQN and the operators that you get with it. So we're doing pretty good. We got 10 minutes left before we got to drop off. And at this point – Yeah, yeah, yeah. I was about to say at this point you got very excited. And, yes, at this point I got very excited.|||这听起来毫无道理，但这就是 APL 和 BQN 以及随之而来的各种运算符的威力。所以我们进展得相当顺利。在我们挂断之前还剩 10 分钟。而此时——对，对，对。我正想说，此时你变得非常兴奋。是的，此时我变得非常兴奋。
Well, this is where we're probably – I'm going to ask this question and you can answer it now, but I'll probably go and find your initial sort of meandering because you know the answer now. And so at this point in the previous recording, which all of my audio got lost, I was like, and so we just did this super fun walkthrough of an APL slash BQN solution to this LeetCode problem, which was super fun, but it was not the point at all. The walkthrough was just extra, you know, icing whatever on the cake. The real question and like the whole buildup to get to this point is what is special about this solution? Because a lot of people, their initial remark is going to be, well, you know, you're creating a bunch of temporary arrays in the form of masks and you're doing all this extra work. Whereas if you just compare it to the implementation of like the two point, the two finger partition solution where, you know,
Well, this is where we're probably – I'm going to ask this question and you can answer it now, but I'll probably go and find your initial sort of meandering because you know the answer now. And so at this point in the previous recording, which all of my audio got lost, I was like, and so we just did this super fun walkthrough of an APL slash BQN solution to this LeetCode problem, which was super fun, but it was not the point at all. The walkthrough was just extra, you know, icing whatever on the cake. The real question and like the whole buildup to get to this point is what is special about this solution? Because a lot of people, their initial remark is going to be, well, you know, you're creating a bunch of temporary arrays in the form of masks and you're doing all this extra work. Whereas if you just compare it to the implementation of like the two point, the two finger partition solution where, you know,|||嗯，这就是我们可能——我要问这个问题，你现在可以回答，但我可能会去找出你最初绕的弯子，因为你现在已经知道答案了。所以在之前的录音中（我的所有音频都丢失了），我当时说：“所以我们刚刚对这个 LeetCode 问题的 APL/BQN 解法进行了一次超级有趣的详细讲解，这非常有趣，但这根本不是重点。这个详细讲解只是锦上添花的东西。”真正的问题以及铺垫了半天要讲到的一点是：这个解法有什么特别之处？因为许多人的第一反应会是：“嗯，你知道的，你以掩码的形式创建了一堆临时数组，并且做了所有这些额外的工作。”而如果你把它与诸如“双指针（two pointer / two finger）partition 解法”的实现进行比较，在这种解法中，你知道的，
you work from the front of the array and the back of the array and you find two that should are in the wrong partitions and then you swap them. Like from a serial or consecutive point of view, that is much more efficient than all this temporary array creating and copying. And so I understand that point of view, but I think this solution is super, super, super awesome sort of in light of that and why people shouldn't be discounting
you work from the front of the array and the back of the array and you find two that should are in the wrong partitions and then you swap them. Like from a serial or consecutive point of view, that is much more efficient than all this temporary array creating and copying. And so I understand that point of view, but I think this solution is super, super, super awesome sort of in light of that and why people shouldn't be discounting|||你从数组的前端和后端同时向中间推进，找到两个处于错误分区的元素并交换它们。从串行或连续的角度来看，这比创建和复制所有这些临时数组要高效得多。我理解那种观点，但鉴于此，我认为这个解法超级、超级、超级棒，而且人们不应该低估
like this way of thinking in array languages and at that point i sort of i put it to bryce and i said bryce do you know why it's so special i think i got it pretty quickly actually which is the answer is that this can be paralyzed oh man so now we're gonna do there where he said i'm pretty sure i got it pretty quickly and then i'm gonna go and go back to what it was because I'm pretty sure I'm pretty sure it took a little bit of handholding because I can't remember what you said. You said a couple of things. And I was like, that's a good point. That's a good point. I didn't think about that. Not what I'm looking for. Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah. Potentially inefficient because you might be generating those Boolean masks twice.
this way of thinking in array languages and at that point i sort of i put it to bryce and i said bryce do you know why it's so special i think i got it pretty quickly actually which is the answer is that this can be paralyzed oh man so now we're gonna do there where he said i'm pretty sure i got it pretty quickly and then i'm gonna go and go back to what it was because I'm pretty sure, I'm pretty sure it took a little bit of handholding because I can't remember what you said. You said a couple of things. And I was like, that's a good point. That's a good point. I didn't think about that. Not what I'm looking for. Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah. Potentially inefficient because you might be generating those Boolean masks twice.|||数组语言中的这种思维方式。就在那时，我向布莱斯提出了这个问题，我说：“布莱斯，你知道为什么它这么特别吗？”“其实我当时觉得我挺快就想到了。”答案是：这可以并行化！天哪，所以现在我们要回到他说的那个场景，当时他说：“我确信我挺快就想到了。”然后我要回到原来的状态，因为我确信，我确信这需要一点引导，因为我记不清你说了什么。你说了好几点。而我的反应是：“这倒是个好点子。这确实是个好点子。我没想到这一点。这不是我要找的答案。”哦，对，对，对。“可能效率低下，因为你可能会生成两次那些布尔掩码。”
Yeah. It doesn't have to be inefficient because you can do the fusion here. If you have this point-free expression, you can go and optimize it so that you only do a single pass. Now this can be paralyzed, can't it? I think I got there pretty quickly. And I think my other points were pretty reasonable points. But then you pointed out that this is actually— That's the important part is that I think I said, yes, it can be paralyzed.
Yeah. It doesn't have to be inefficient because you can do the fusion here. If you have this point-free expression, you can go and optimize it so that you only do a single pass. Now this can be paralyzed, can't it? I think I got there pretty quickly. And I think my other points were pretty reasonable points. But then you pointed out that this is actually— That's the important part is that I think I said, yes, it can be paralyzed.|||是的。它不一定低效率，因为你可以在这里做融合（fusion）。如果你有这样一个无参数表达式（point-free expression），你可以去优化它，以便只进行单次遍历。现在这可以并行化，对吧？我觉得我挺快就想通了。而且我认为我的其他观点也相当合理。但随后你指出，这其实——重要的一部分是，我想我说过：“是的，它可以并行化。”
But even more exciting than it just being parallelizable um like take it a step further like what what am i what am i actually really excited about and then what did i this is this is the current algorithm uh that thrust uses to implement its parallel partition correct and so and so, and that was, and that was what, uh, after having done this the first time I did this a couple of months ago, uh, when I was, you know, just messing around, I thought, I wonder how thrust partition actually does this. And then when I went to the thrust partition docs very quickly, you could see it's not identical to what's happening here, but you're basically, you're creating some temporary storage, using it to, I mean, we will follow up with this in a follow-up episode, which is what Bryce was referring to earlier, that there's a count if that happens, a thrust count if, to figure out how many elements are going to be in the first partition so you know where to start the second partition.
But even more exciting than it just being parallelizable um like take it a step further like what what am i what am i actually really excited about and then what did i this is this is the current algorithm uh that thrust uses to implement its parallel partition correct and so and so, and that was, and that was what, uh, after having done this the first time I did this a couple of months ago, uh, when I was, you know, just messing around, I thought, I wonder how thrust partition actually does this. And then when I went to the thrust partition docs very quickly, you could see it's not identical to what's happening here, but you're basically, you're creating some temporary storage, using it to, I mean, we will follow up with this in a follow-up episode, which is what Bryce was referring to earlier, that there's a count if that happens, a thrust count if, to figure out how many elements are going to be in the first partition so you know where to start the second partition.|||但比它仅仅能够并行化更令人兴奋的是，嗯，再深入一步——我、我真正兴奋的点到底是什么？然后我——这就是，这就是 Thrust 目前用来实现其并行 partition 的算法，对吧？所以，所以，那是——那是，呃，几个月前我第一次做这个的时候，呃，当我（你知道的）只是在随便鼓捣时，我想：“我很好奇 Thrust 的 partition 实际上是怎么做的。”然后当我快速浏览 Thrust 的 partition 文档时，你可以看到它与这里发生的情况不尽相同，但你基本上是创建了一些临时存储，用它来——我的意思是，我们会在后续的节目中跟进这一点，正如布莱斯刚才所提到的，其中会发生一次 count_if，即 thrust::count_if，用来计算第一个分区中将有多少个元素，这样你就能知道第二个分区该从哪里开始。
What do you want to say? Well, I was going to say that perhaps more specifically that the way that Thrust implements this today is there's three passes, I believe. There's a count if to figure out the size of each of the partitions. And then there's two copy ifs, one for the true cases and one for the false cases. And during our discussions last time, I think I came to the conclusion that, and I should add a caveat here. And the caveat is, for basically all of the stable algorithms in thrust for stable sort and stable partition,
What do you want to say? Well, I was going to say that perhaps more specifically that the way that Thrust implements this today is there's three passes, I believe. There's a count if to figure out the size of each of the partitions. And then there's two copy ifs, one for the true cases and one for the false cases. And during our discussions last time, I think I came to the conclusion that, and I should add a caveat here. And the caveat is, for basically all of the stable algorithms in thrust for stable sort and stable partition,|||你想说什么？嗯，我正要说的是，可能更具体地说，Thrust 今天实现这一点的方式大概需要三次遍历。首先是一个 count_if，用来算出每个分区的大小。然后是两次 copy_if，一次针对为真的情况，另一次针对为假的情况。在我们上次的讨论中，我想我得出了这样一个结论——我在这里应该补充一个前提。这个前提是，对于 Thrust 中基本上所有的稳定算法（用于稳定排序和稳定分区），
the same algorithm is used for the stable version and the unstable version. Right. Just because there has not been a benefit in doing something different. And I think in the case of sort, there's not really an option that would, like a parallel sort option that would be unstable. Now, interestingly, once we started talking about this for partition, we realized that perhaps we could do an unstable partition faster. And then I think we came to the conclusion that we might even be able to do the stable partition faster. But basically, we quickly came to the conclusion we probably don't need to do that count if, so we can get rid of that pass.
the same algorithm is used for the stable version and the unstable version. Right. Just because there has not been a benefit in doing something different. And I think in the case of sort, there's not really an option that would, like a parallel sort option that would be unstable. Now, interestingly, once we started discussing this for partition, we realized that perhaps we could do an unstable partition faster. And then I think we came to the conclusion that we might even be able to do the stable partition faster. But basically, we quickly came to the conclusion we probably don't need to do that count if, so we can get rid of that pass.|||稳定版本和不稳定版本使用的是相同的算法。没错。只是因为做不同的事情并没有带来什么好处。而且我认为就 sort 而言，其实并没有那种——比如会是不稳定的并行排序的选项。现在，有趣的是，一旦我们开始就 partition 讨论这一点，我们就意识到，也许我们可以更快地完成不稳定分区。然后我认为我们得出的结论是，我们甚至可能更快地完成稳定分区。但基本上，我们很快得出结论：我们可能不需要执行那个 count_if，因此我们可以省去那一轮遍历。
And then we just have those two copy ifs. And the way that you could avoid doing that count if is that if the copy ifs, instead of them both starting at the front of the sequence, if you have a type of iterator where you can get a reverse iterator, then one copy if starts at the front, one starts at the back, and you don't need to figure out
And then we just have those two copy ifs. And the way that you could avoid doing that count if is that if the copy ifs, instead of them both starting at the front of the sequence, if you have a type of iterator where you can get a reverse iterator, then one copy if starts at the front, one starts at the back, and you need to figure out|||然后我们只需保留那两次 copy_if 即可。你可以避免执行那个 count_if 的方法是：如果这两个 copy_if 不是都从序列的前端开始，而是如果你有一种迭代器类型可以获取反向迭代器（reverse iterator），那么一个 copy_if 从前端开始，另一个从后端开始，而你只需要弄清楚
where the second copy if is going to need to begin. And you just have potential stability problems. But then the other thing that sort of occurred to me is, you know, well, if that's the case, couldn't we just do it in one, you know, in one pass? Um, uh, uh, and I think that might be, I think that might be possible. And I think that's what we're going to explore in some future, some future episode. Yeah. I definitely think the, the two pass one it's it's, it should be more than than possible the one i'll have to see if what you're thinking one pass with owen keep in mind here we have an assumption of owen temporary storage so we don't have to do it all in place um the algorithm
第二份 copy_if 需要开始的地方。然后你就会遇到潜在的稳定性问题。但随后我脑海中浮现的另一件事是，你知道的，好吧，如果真是这样，我们为什么不能在一趟（pass）内完成呢？嗯，呃，呃，而且我认为这可能是，我认为这可能是可能的。而且我认为这就是我们将在未来的一些，未来的一些节目中探讨的内容。是的。我绝对认为两趟的版本，它，它应该是非常可能的，单趟的那种我还得看看你所想的单趟加上，记住这里我们假设有临时存储，所以我们不需要全部就地（in place）完成，呃，这个算法
today already use it so the algorithm today is three passes and uses own temporary storage um like apparently not a lot of people are doing uh parallel partitions because like the current algorithm is slow um so it was clearly never a big priority for us to optimize it but if you are doing a parallel partition um we're going to make it faster although you know slow on a gpu sometimes can still be yeah still be a lot faster than whatever you're doing. The case of – there's one reason that the one-pass version that I have in mind might be slower than the two-pass version. And it sort of gets into our efficiency versus speed episode from a while back. Um, that one pass algorithm might be branchy. Um, uh, and so if you, if you have to do a single pass on a GPU where that single pass has an if statement, sometimes that's going to be,
今天就已经在使用它了，所以今天的算法是三趟的，并且使用了自己的临时存储，呃，就像显然没有多少人在做，呃，并行分区，因为像当前的算法很慢，呃，所以这显然从来不是我们优化的一个大优先级，但如果你在做一个并行分区，呃，我们会让它更快，虽然你知道，在GPU上有时慢仍然可以，是的，仍然比你正在做的任何事情快得多。的情况是——我脑海中构思的单趟版本比两趟版本慢，有一个原因。这就涉及到了我们前段时间关于效率与速度的那期节目。呃，那个单趟算法可能会有许多分支（branchy）。呃，呃，所以如果你，如果你必须在GPU上执行一个单趟，而这个单趟包含一个if语句，有时这将会
uh, slower than doing two passes where there's no if statement in each of the passes. But we'll see. We're going to explore all that. It's going to be awesome. Yeah. Live coding. We're going to start a whole series on refactoring and increasing the perf of thrust algorithms. And a great note to finish on, which I just realized as Bryce was explaining, you know, how the thrust partition algorithm
比执行没有if语句的两个趟要慢。但我们会拭目以待。我们将探讨所有这些。这将会非常棒。是的，实时编码。我们将围绕重构和提高thrust算法性能开启整个系列。这是一个很好的收尾点，就在布莱斯解释的时候我突然意识到，你知道，thrust分区算法是如何
works and how it could be, you know, enhanced or improved the vocabulary that we're using here. Like, this is why, this is why you should learn your algorithms going back to the whole C plus plus seasoning, you know, Sean parent, you know, know your algorithms. And then a bunch of people popularizing that sentiment is the vocabulary that we're using to talk about doing this is algorithms. We're not talking about for loops or, or, you know, kernels or all this stuff, the lower level pieces that we could build this in. We're talking about a count if a couple of copy ifs, we're talking about a transform iterator, which is just sort of a,
工作的，以及它如何能够被，你知道的，增强或改进，我们在这里使用的词汇。就像，这就是为什么，这就是为什么你应该学习你的算法，回到整个C++老手的话题，你知道的，肖恩·帕伦特（Sean Parent），你知道的，了解你的算法。然后许多人普及了这种情绪，我们用来讨论这件事的词汇是算法。我们讨论的不是for循环，或者，你知道的，内核，或者所有这些我们可以用来构建它的底层组件。我们讨论的是一个 count_if，几个 copy_if，我们讨论的是一个变换迭代器（transform iterator），它其实就是某种意义上的
you know, the equivalent of a transform algorithm. But that, you know, just to show it does it on demand or lazily. And in my opinion, your ability to like, we are communicating at a higher level than is possible if we don't have the names of these operations, which I just think that there's a lot of folks that, you know, you'll give a talk on algorithms and then they'll come up afterwards and they'll say, oh, is it really worth it? You know, it's a bunch of effort to go and learn, you know, all the different, you know, names of these algorithms in every different library. And that's the thing is like the standard algorithms, which is sure these are in thrust, but they're all equivalents of what exists in these standard algorithms. It's not something that you like, you have to go learn n different times.
你知道的，变换算法的等价物。但你知道，这只是为了表明它是按需或延迟（lazily）执行的。在我看来，你沟通的能力，我们正在以一种比没有这些操作名称时更高的水平进行交流，我认为有很多人，你知道的，你做完关于算法的演讲后，他们会走过来问，哦，这真的值得吗？你知道，去学习所有不同库中所有这些不同算法的名字需要付出很多努力。关键就在于标准算法，当然这些在thrust中，但它们都与标准算法中存在的东西相对应。这不是那种你必须去学习N次的东西。
You learn it once and it's now enhancing the vocabulary with which you can communicate with your coworkers, which I don't know how this. It's all about composition too right it's it's that um the the algorithms on them on their own aren't particularly useful the the interesting thing is the ways in which you can compose and you compose them together and combine them in the way in which you can compose and you compose them together and combine them in the way in which you can write your own algorithms just by plugging the right operators into right the existing algorithms um like you know like reduce if reduced like only added up integers like that's not a very exciting algorithm um but think about you know think about all of the things we've done on this podcast with you know the the notion of a reduction
你只需要学一次，它现在就增强了你与同事沟通的词汇量，我不知道这怎么说。这也完全关乎组合，对吧，就是呃，算法本身并不是特别有用，有趣的是你可以组合它们的方式，你可以把它们组合在一起，通过将正确的运算符插入到现有的算法中，你就可以编写自己的算法，就像，你知道的，比如 reduce_if，reduce 就像只把整数相加一样——那不是一个非常令人兴奋的算法——但想想，你知道的，想想我们在本播客中用归约（reduction）的概念做过的所有事情
um uh and like under understanding that pattern that algorithmic structure um is in understanding how you can use it and combine it with that algorithmic structure, and understanding how you can use it and combine it with other algorithmic structures is really powerful. Yeah, I completely agree. And on that note, we'll wrap it there because that's such a good note to end it. And we have to go in four minutes.
呃，就像理解那个模式，那个算法结构，就是在理解如何使用它并将其与那个算法结构相结合，以及理解如何使用它并将其与其他算法结构相结合是非常强大的。是的，我完全同意。就此而言，我们就到此结束吧，因为这是一个非常好的结束点。我们必须在四分钟内离开。
So thanks for listening. We hope you enjoyed and have a great day. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
感谢收听。希望你喜欢，祝你有美好的一天。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。